[Music]
this one comes from dylan dylan asks how
do you negotiate the value of the
company you're selling so how did you
come up with the price how did you get
to a price with you with your company
when you sold it i made a huge mistake
i
made a classic mistake i
said the number first i said these
companies typically sell for
blank x and blank x and of course the
first offer they asked you like what's
your what are your expectations or
what's a brain what do you what price
would you be happy with what are they
how do they ask it
i don't even know if they asked it but
i said oh you know
i think i said like
look like it's i'm not i said i'm not
gonna mess around like so these
companies typically sell for blank to
blank so if you're in the market let me
know and
the first offer was the low number of
that
and last offer was it the high number or
somewhere in the middle
in the well
so it was in the middle but like the
thing is is that when we sold the
company the hubspot stock was 350
and basically a week later it was like
you could look it up it was like 550 and
then like
three months after that it was like 850
right so like it changed the sale price
was one thing but it pretty much changed
quickly but it was like right in the
middle of that number but um
i made a huge mistake i should not have
done that and
as soon as i said that i was like [__]
[__] [__] and you say you get an email
did i say it an email i think you said i
think i don't know it sounds like the
story you're sending it you saying you
said it in an email i don't remember uh
no i think i said it on the phone and
there's the woman who i'm now friends
with who was doing the deal [__]
lashed onto that like a shark and she
told and i knew it and afterwards i i
i'm friends with her now she doesn't
even work out spot and i'm like you
you got me a badge like yeah like you
said the number
and the great thing to do is after you
negotiate a deal
go talk to the person once you're once
your pals and you're on the same team
say look we're on the same team for sure
uh but man negotiating that was so
you know confusing for me
uh what did i do poorly you know like
what would you have what do you think
you would have gone up to make me hate
myself what would you what do you think
you could have gone up to and you just
ask a bunch of questions to try to suss
out
what got them interested what made them
hesitant how they figured out the value
what they were willing to negotiate to
what mistakes you made in negotiation
because you get so few reps at
negotiating it's important to do that
but it sounds like to answer dylan's
question you did two things you said
first you looked up comparables so you
found out comparable sales so that's how
you got a range and then you
made the [__] up in your actual
negotiation of that range to like you
you you actually set up the proper range
and it probably cost me
it cost me many millions of dollars
right it's like that one decision you
made actually was more important than
like the previous two years of operating
probably yeah
yeah how did you do it
um
we i did not say a number right away um
i [__] up in one regard which was
i let my emotion so when we so the way
we decided to sell was there was nobody
coming knocking on our door saying
you we need to buy you you're the best
uh we we we're we want to be in the
business of you
i was basically frankly i saw the
writing on the wall for my business i
was like okay i think this is not zero
but it's not gonna be huge so what do i
wanna do do i wanna ride out a middle of
the pack like
small like medium sized outcome for the
next five years
or can i just go flip this thing now and
i decided i wanna go flip this thing now
i was also really tired because i had
been doing i've been trying to find
product market fit with different
startups in our idea lab for like six
years i was ready for a change in
general
and so i told my investor my co-founder
i said hey
i want to sell this thing i think it's
time and they were like okay if you want
to sell then let's sell and i said all
right let me let me run a process i'm
going to try to sell this in the next 45
days so first that was good because i
time boxed it but i also
you know like uh
it added a lot of pressure and so the
mistake i made when i was figuring out
how how to sell i was
i let my emotions of the day
dictate how i sold how how hard i sold
the company so what does that mean
at first i was super confident they're
going to want to buy us so i went to two
or three companies with my super like
swagged out
uh like
cocky cocky like pitch basically which
was sort of like
yeah everybody wants us but like you
know so if you guys are interested you
know you you basically like
uh you got to let us know because this
is moving fast with you know these other
people so you we we got approached
we're interested we might go that path
you're either going to get on the train
now or you're going to miss it so i was
like kind of cocky confident that was
like working but then like two days
would go by where like somebody you know
they didn't text me back or they said
they were gonna review the thing and
email me and they didn't email me so
then i started to i have doubt creep
into my head a little bit so then i
would like kind of like it's like a
booty call like desperation reach out to
some other company and so one of them
was i reached out to facebook through
somebody i know and i was sort of like
hey like you know we're going to sell
this thing i used the word aquahire
which was like the wrong word to say
because aquahire means a specific range
of what outcome you're going to get and
it basically means
don't value my company just value my
talent
and um i shouldn't have done that i
should not have said that there i was
luckily able to recover because it was
such a big company that by the time he
made the intro to the person who made
the intro
i had like changed the narrative
completely but the third guy was like
yeah you guys looking at aquarius like i
don't know where the [__] you got that
no and it's like
i literally had sent an email and you
know with myself saying that but i
luckily was able to change it and
actually they they came in with the
facebook camera with the highest offer
and so we and so i ended up
recovering from that mistake but that
could have been critically bad would you
wish you would have taken the facebook
offer
no uh like the amazon offer ended up
working out great but um
you know whatever it was a good deal uh
in the end i guess but but that was the
main thing and i didn't have a
comparable i didn't have comparables
really i kind of the comparables i heard
were such a huge range but i was like
okay
i just need to forget i heard any of
those numbers because it's too wide of a
range it just means like
it depends
and so then i started negotiating i
didn't say the number first
and we waited till we got offers
they tried to get a number out of us but
i was like not gonna do it and um
i was anchoring in other ways besides
saying the specific number i was like
leaving little hints or kind of just
like
you know just making sure they knew that
we had other interests
and eventually once we got one offer i
was like okay that's a ballpark and then
i basically just texted the ceo of
twitch and i was like hey
i'm gonna take this other offer unless
you can match and uh he's like you know
give me some time let me give me some
time i was like i don't have time he's
like give me an hour and i was like okay
i'll give you the hour and uh and then
he came back with an offer that wasn't
quite a match but it was good enough
where i said okay all other factors
considered we think this is the best
because they were going to take more of
our team and other stuff that the other
one wasn't going to do
it's such a stressful period
yeah it's such a stressful period
yeah nobody teaches you how to do this
and it's like the most important thing
you'll do as the ceo of your company is
land the plane but it's like being a
pilot and you learned everything about
takeoff and flight and you've never
heard anyone mention how the [__] you're
supposed to land and so you're like just
kind of pointing downwards and you're
trying to land the thing based on like
instinct and then like a few fuzzy
messages you get from mentors
or you use like if you use an investment
bank it's different but we were not at
that size you got to be doing like 50
million to 100 million minimum
in your sale price to be um to have a
banker who does it for you
dude i had this roommate named james
and like he was like a stoner pothead
and like like the first day of work at
his new job he went and he had a teacher
that said i heart weed i just really
think i love wheat instead of i love new
york and uh he um
he was negotiating a salary for a
company vungle jack's company that i
introduced him to and he'd been on
unemployed for 10 months and he'd been
struggling to find a company that he
wanted to work at and i think he was
using like his mom's credit card to pay
the bills because i would get like
uh his statements and like so i thought
like maybe things were going south for
him i'm like dude i don't know if you
have much money left i don't know how
you're gonna pay rent and vungle made
him an offer for like
a hundred and ninety thousand dollars to
be an engineer at their company and he
told me and he goes are you are you
gonna take it and he like exhales weed
and he was like
i don't know man i'm not sure if it's
worth my time i'm going to make him
sweat a little bit
and
he
i was like james are you kidding me dude
i'm like you don't have any money you've
been interviewing and talking to kids
for 10 months you're screwed he goes
yeah let's make him sweat and i get a
phone call from the recruiter who i
introduced him to and like he goes dude
james is like a hot engineer right now
like i don't know if we're gonna be able
to land him like he's just bargaining so
hard and i don't think we're gonna get
this guy
and i was like i put the phone down like
oh james do you hear what they're
[__] saying you better come to an
agreement soon and i go well you know
just give him what he wants like who
knows give what he wants
you just gotta land him and i hung up
and they ended up upping his offer and
he negotiated from a place of having
nothing and you didn't care at all and i
learned from him that day that that's
actually a really good place to
negotiate from so long as you're willing
to accept these horrible consequences
yeah i got to actually say that that was
the most useful thing like how we sold
our company was i was totally okay if
nobody bought it because i was kind of
excited
about just
ending it and going and doing something
completely different like i was kind of
like a maniac in that way i was like
okay look if
i got zero millions out of this if i got
zero dollars
i'm actually kind of excited about that
path too so i was like pretty free in
that way whereas i think
you had a real business that was
producing real revenues and profits you
didn't have that option of like
not a good like you know
not getting a good offer you needed i
felt that way though where i was like
i'm done i'm out
i was like like i just i need to get out
of here
so i i felt this the same way as you uh
and i'll learn a little bit differently
how to run things so you don't get burnt
out
[Music]
you